[Music]
the problem in society we have at the
moment
is everyone is afraid of making a
mistake what
may happen if we don't do anything
the pandemic has changed life as we know
it
but what comes next will our fast-paced
lives pick up again
will we continue to innovate regardless
of the cost
live limes profit driven
and globally connected
or has this pandemic sparked irrevocable
change
how will we live in the future after the
pandemic
[Music]
hello and welcome to dw's coveted 19
special i'm stephen beardsley in berlin
well all this week we're taking a look
ahead at life after the pandemic
from what it means for cities to
economies even nutrition
today climate change as the world
focuses on getting past the pandemic
the urgency of climate change has taken
a bit of a back seat
but slowing global warming could
actually be critical for preventing
future disease scientists warn that a
warming planet will provide fertile
ground for viruses and other pathogens
and introduce disease carriers to new
habitats
a german climate activist and author
david nellis has been mapping out some
of those dangers
he spoke with us earlier take a listen
yeah one example is the tiger mosquito
which spreads the dengue fever into
chicago virus
in the past it lived just in the south
east asian regions but because of
climate change it's warmer here
so the mosquito came comes to europe and
therefore the risks increases to be
infected with tropical diseases even
here in germany or the united kingdom
german climate activist and author david
nellis there
and for more on this let's talk with
arun najam he's dean of the party school
of global affairs at boston university
professor najam thank you so much for
joining us this connection
between changes in wildlife habitat and
disease
has the pandemic helped make this clear
to normal people and perhaps added some
urgency to climate change
i hope it will i'm not sure it has
certainly at the beginning of the
pandemic i think there was a bit of fear
mongering about
how it had come we were all concerned
worried about you know how did it get
here
and because we realized that it had
transmuted from sort of the geological
system into the human system
there was this concern that maybe we
will again sort of start looking at
nature as the enemy but i
hope what will happen and is happening
not as much as i would like
but i hope that the right message is
that we have to live
in co-existence with nature that nature
is a huge thing
that nature is what nourishes us and if
we restrict the space of nature if we
restrict the space of biodiversity
then nature will hit back in the ways
for example that your guest was talking
about with dengue
or in the way that we have seen with
coronavirus that in some ways the big
lesson is
that there is no human health without
ecological health
that the two come together let's talk
about the management of climate change
managing the pandemic has required an
incredible amount of collective action
and sacrifice
which climate change will also require
based on what you've seen so far from
the pandemic
should we be optimistic or pessimistic
about the fight against climate change
at this point i'm neither but i do do
hope that we should be very reflective
about what has happened we should try to
think about okay what
what just happened what did we learn
about ourselves about our own behavior
and we should be very concerned in some
ways this pandemic gives you an early
warning if you will
of what a truly or a reminder because
we've had this before what a truly
global
crisis looks like you know we've talked
about climate as
as as a crisis possibly in the future
and having this in your face
makes you think and should make you
think there are good lessons and there
are some disturbing lessons the
disturbing lesson is that
this was not a very global moment our
immediate reaction especially in the
beginning was closing up
was getting tribal was building walls
was trying to blame the other was trying
to put
what put things out hey i i have too
many too many problems myself i can't
share my ventilators i can't really
give you my masks if you go back to
march of last year
the good lesson if you want is the
lesson of vaccine development for
example the lesson of science coming in
to help the lesson of
listening to knowledge and in a way the
choice that we will make
will determine the future in some ways
the sad part is and this is what is very
much like climate change
you know we sometimes act surprised that
the pandemic happened but there was no
surprise in the pandemic we knew about
pandemics we talked about pandemics we
prepared
or we said we prepared for pandemics and
yet
when it came we had ignored it so often
that we were found totally unprepared
that is exactly the story with climate
change
at the same time it happens no one has
the right to feel surprised
when we look at climate change versus
the pandemic the pandemic has very
specific in that is we all get to a
certain number of vaccines we reach herd
immunity
with climate change there's no solid
there there
perhaps does that make it more difficult
for someone to imagine tackling climate
change versus the pandemic
it might it might make it more difficult
but it also makes it more urgent you're
exactly right climate change does not
have a vaccine
whether it is pfizer or moderna or
astrazeneca or whatever
they're not going to come up with a
vaccine or a pill that you're going to
pop in and climate change will be solved
yes there are ways with what's called
adaptation we will have to adapt
an adaptation will not be comfortable
and adaptation will not
be be cheap and again we've learned that
independent
in the pandemic you know what does
adaptation means something bad happens
and you adapt to it you learn to live
with it so you build your buildings
higher if sea sea level is rising uh
i wear the sweater because it is cold i
am adapting but that is exactly
think about what we did with the
pandemic we adapted we learned how to
wear a mask
we learned how to lock ourselves up we
learned how to not meet
friends we learned how to not hug people
we love
how that is what adaptation is and the
lesson is adaptation is
not comfortable how much harder will
that shift be will those adaptations be
especially as we're going from the end
of the pandemic
to climate change i get the feeling that
not many people are in the mood to talk
about personal sacrifice right now
but they'd rather be rewarded for a
period in which they feel like they've
already sacrificed a lot so maybe
taking more trips things like that yeah
i i think i think you're right i i in a
way i don't want to begrudge them sort
of going out
and sort of you know after having been
locked up for a year
but on the other hand this is why this
should be a moment of reflection
this should be a moment of learning
because we've also done so many things
right we
we have learned good lessons we have
learned the lesson that if you spend a
dollar
in advance to avert a crisis
you will save millions of dollars when
if the crisis hits
so i think those are the lessons that
come now in terms of climate and
pandemic in particular
in the beginning there was a little sort
of thought that okay we won't be driving
as much and we won't be
using energy as much and the consumption
will go down
i'm not sure that has exactly happened
maybe it's happened in a few cases
to the extent it has happened you know
climate strategy should not be locking
people up in their homes
and on the other hand we have found that
you know we are a consumptive species we
find new ways to consume
we pay other people to come and and
travel on our behalf and emit carbon on
our behalf and develop
and and drop food at our doorsteps but
we
are a we are a smart species
we should learn from this i hope the
biggest lesson we learn
is not that we will all become sort of
self-sacrificing
that that's the i don't think that's how
it will solve it the question is not
self-sacrifice this question is smart
behavior
we do not get pleasure out of emitting
carbon
we get pleasure out of quality of life
and i hope what the pandemic also
teaches us is
that quality of life means more than
just
getting into your car and getting stuck
in traffic all right we'll have to leave
it there for now
professor adal najam with boston
university thank you so much for joining
us
and let's check in now with our science
correspondent derek williams for another
question related to climate change
demand for meat is growing and that has
consequences for human health and the
environment
how is science trying to address this
problem our hunger for
meat contributes in a major way to
climate change
and environmental degradation and the
conditions
in which billions of animals are kept
also poses a direct health threat to
humanity since
experts say intensive animal agriculture
provides a nearly perfect breeding
ground
for pathogens to evolve but people
aren't going to want to start eating
less meat from one day to the next
demand for it is actually growing at a
dizzying pace
so what's science doing to help
improve the paradigm well two things
jump instantly to mind one
is all that research behind plant-based
uh meat alternatives that that look and
taste
like the real thing but are mostly made
from ingredients like soy or
or peas or mushrooms discoveries
in a range of scientific fields
especially those that involve
how we process taste and texture
are improving the experience of eating
those products which is reflected
by a recent big boom in demand
the other science driven approach to the
meat problem involves the
the cutting edge field of cultivated or
or cultured meat
it's based on the fact that the animals
themselves
are actually pretty inefficient meat
factories
lots of what you put in comes back out
again as
as problematic waste or it goes towards
creating
unwanted byproducts like like skin or
bone
so so why not just grow only what you
want
the meat directly from the right types
of cells
replicated in in giant bio reactors
the science behind doing that in in a
commercially
viable way has actually proven pretty
finicky maybe
you remember the hype around the first a
lab-grown
burger back in 2013 which cost 250
000 euros to make
but the technology has come a long way
since then and and production costs
are coming down fast cultured chicken
nuggets
were sold commercially for the first
time in january in singapore
many analysts predict we'll see cleaner
greener antibiotic-free cultured meat
on store shelves in the next few years
and the big question of course is how
willing people
will be to buy it
[Music]
our own science expert derek williams
there that's it for us today thanks for
watching
stay safe and we'll see you again soon